[Music]
women's swimwear is uncomfortable all
right to be honest I am a little
self-conscious I know there's one piece
and I know there's a bikini
yes that's it I mean how many suits
could there be
oh man I feel like 20 pounds the 10
pound bag Oh No even worse than I
imagined would it be good if I cried
during this evil booty view here's
what's going on down there
my balls are spilling out the front hole
but she is out but I dig it
this has just got too much going on I'm
more of like a simple kind of guy it
looks so much better you can see my
nipple this looks like some yeah
abstract painting I look like I'm like
the bad guy from some kind of bondage
torture porn I've never had my nipples
covered like this before
oh yeah hanging out this is this is the
butt part just you can see it's all it's
in the worst places of my body my dick
is just like chillin right there people
to see not even a percentage of my dick
is out the entire dick is that I don't
like side dick that's not a thing
whatever want to see sidekick I don't
want to see side dick if you saw me
running down a beach you would be
terrified you should never feel like you
have to wear this ever
I feel like I just popped out of a
birthday cake Oh
oh my god you think I like hi I'm never
gonna look at myself the same feel a
little better about this one I like the
color it's like kind of slimming a
little more comfortable I imagine if you
had boobs wouldn't look as strange makes
my butt look good this feels like an old
bathing suit like this feels old-school
this feels Minton I feel like there's
something very sexy about the time where
I just naturally want to do that like
let the girls breathe even though this
has the most fabric even though it's the
least revealing I feel the sexiest legs
not out to play my ass is like nice and
covered I mean there is the threat of my
nipple popping out but I mean you gotta
give something up right the bottoms are
so comfortable I feel really good I feel
like I can do anything
this is definitely like a mom outfit I
couldn't get anything done in my life I
would have had to be tit checking 24
hours a day and those other banks it's
not surprising to me that it's the one I
like the best I was kind of shocked at
how difficult they were to put on to
keep on to where to move in I think guys
are more geared towards comfort whereas
girls and more geared towards showing up
your assets
I think women should wear whatever
whatever they feel good in takes a lot
of courage just to wear a bathing suit
to all my haters eat this whatever you
get half a nip it's fine